so one of the unexpected games Nintendo
announc 83 that we just finally got new
information from during their Nintendo
Direct is code name steam the strategy
game coming from ntelligent systems they
make strategy games typically like Fire
Emblem Advanced Wars but there's
something about Cod steam that just
feels really different I whenever we're
describing the game we always say you
know from the Creator as a fire emblem
because that's what's recognizable but
this is nothing like a straight of Fire
Emblem this is much more I think like
XCOM it's like XCOM on your 3DS because
it's a tactical strategy game you're
playing it from the the point of view of
your character well from the third
person point of view of your character
and you're able to guide them around the
the the map and fire on enemies and and
that's all happening in real time but
you get to take your turn before the
enemies take theirs and you have your
whole Squad and you kind of move them
around and position them in on the map
and then the enemies take their turn and
you fight against them you can set up
sort of like these preemptive
counterattacks by you know because every
move that you make when it's your turn
costs a certain amount of energy uh so
if you conserve some of that you can
actually set yourself up so that if an
enemy comes in range of one of your
characters you can negate their turn and
sort of maybe even stun them at one
point or another which seem to be like a
really important part of this game when
it comes to strategizing but at the same
time you're always going to get waves
and waves of enemies so what they were
telling us is that to keep you from just
like taking a couple steps and then
keeping your meter maxed out so that you
are going to be able to Counterattack
the longer you wait the more enemies are
going to start coming in on screen so
you still want to be able to you want to
push it you don't want to just hang back
the entire time so you have to balance
that like do I need to be able to
retaliate or is it safe for me to just
kind of Branch out and start exploring I
think another neat aspect of this or or
at least interesting is that the speed
of your character matters in in terms of
enemies noticing you so if you sneak if
you walk slowly and carefully they're
not going to hear you coming you'll
you'll be able to actually sneak up on
enemies and you do this by just moving
the analog like a small amount right but
if you yeah if you jam the analog stick
if you do go into a run you're going to
make a lot of noise your character says
like oh I'm making a lot of noise
enemies are going to know notice you and
they're going to start trying to come
towards you and start attacking you yeah
the uh a lot of the uh the weapons in
this game are sort of you know like some
of them are like really mechanical based
they're like you're fighting aliens but
you don't really have like a selection
of sci-fi based weapons I mean this is
based in the age of steam you know
everything is very sort of archaic and
rudimentary that way so each of your
characters has a primary weapon like
something that they always have equipped
and then you have the sub weapon which
is something that you can choose and
most of those seem not necessarily
generic those are your standard things
like the shotgun and the rifle but the
weapon that your character comes
equipped with can can actually change
how you react to the battlefield like so
there's the lion from The Wizard of Oz
which that's just a weird choice for a
character his primary weapon is a lion
launcher that lets him boost himself up
over obstacles and go over fences and
he's the only character who can get to
some of these high up places or to
Traverse some of the the obstacles that
you come across because he has a gun
that launches himself yeah and he's not
not the only character from sort of like
American folklore I guess he wouldn't
really call that folklore but you know
what I mean uh so there's there's John
Henry the guy who I think famously like
fought to to Chisel his way through a
mountain like you know against a machine
um but then you've also got Abe Lincoln
who is sort of the president who is
directing you to fight back against
these aliens it's a weird mix of
characters you have Tom Sawyer from
literature but you also have Tiger Lily
which is a random Native American and a
pumpkin head guy that's a guy with a
pumpkin on his head yeah it's a very
strange game I mean it it definitely has
like like when I was playing it I felt
tuned into the Strategic sort of combat
you know that the game is basically
built upon but the rest of it to for me
was really hard to kind of attach myself
to in a meaningful way I like granted
like most of the games from intelligence
systems have always been cartoony
characters but these
are they're so different that I don't
know if I'm going to be able to on to
them I I don't even notice the
characters like I the whole Situation's
kind of ridiculous and the story is
whatever but they intelligent systems
just makes really great combat systems
and I just felt myself getting drawn
into to the combat itself and trying to
strategize how could I go around this it
felt a little easy because as long as
you get one character to the end you're
going to make it it's not like that that
difficulty of Fire Emblem where you have
perade death where your character's
choices really really matter everyone
can get everyone can pass out in this
game as long as one guy makes it to the
end you're fine so in in that sense it
feels a little more simplistic but at
the same time like I want to know I want
to find all the little secrets in the
map and I want to get all of my
characters alive to the
end